[Music]
this morning on the dish
omar tate he was just named chef of the
year by
esquire but his vision's way beyond just
running a restaurant
tate's combination of cooking poetry and
art is delivering powerful lessons
recently dan barber of blue hill at
stone barns one of the most famous
restaurants in the country
handed his kitchen and restaurant over
to tate as part of a series of guest
chefs
and for us tate put together one of the
most interesting dinners
we have ever seen
i say to people that i'm a chef just
because it's easier for people to
understand what i do
but i really consider myself an artist
and a teacher
for omar tate it's never been about just
the food
it's the music poetry and message
all in service of sharing his experience
as a black american
that's why as the chef in residence at
stone barns
he curated a gallery space where diners
can immerse themselves in his work
before eating in the kitchen he began
preparing for us
a dish called black lung a terrarium for
black breath
it's a salad so the irony in this dish
is that
the dish itself is an acknowledgement of
death and the loss of black lives
but is presented in like a life force
through
through a living salad essentially there
are a couple of different aspects here
that represent
body right so we have some chicken bones
on the plate that are that are not
edible
um but you know like grease sets in
people's bones and so this is
represented spiritually in that way on
this dish
and then chicken fried mushrooms are
kind of play against the sterile type of
black folks
that would eventually make its way to
our table along with the rest of his
stunning spread first up his version of
kool-aid
a staple of his youth with dried
strawberries
oh that's good it's pretty tasty i mean
this is this is not your um
it's not your father it's not your
mama's kool-aid
which is no disrespect to mom but this
is amazing
everything tate prepares has a story
even under the plates
they're served on that signature salad
black lung is delivered on a cement
cast of the sidewalk outside his
mother's house in west philadelphia
the display and converse with the notion
of conflict and urban spaces in life
notes from a black pantry has yams
cabbage and carrots
it's a still life it's a representation
of a still life of a photo that i took
of my wife's kitchen
and there's an all black dish called
clorindy named for the 1898 musical by
paul lawrence dunbar and william marion
cook
beef tartar stained black with squid ink
and encased in a rice wafer shell
which represents a glass ceiling meant
to be shattered which one do we eat with
your hands no is it really no the fork
you're messing with yeah the sublime
parker house roll is made with
sweet potatoes inside i'm extremely
influenced
by you can go ahead and say it's
delicious it's fine
it is delicious everyone everyone's like
like going bananas over these but
the bakery department here did such a
great job i was really influenced by
george washington carver and his use of
crops
specifically the sweet potato crop so
this is roasted sweet potato in the
center with butter and the
you know butter makes everything better
yeah it's awesome then
there are the desserts including
honeysuckle ice cream
and a black walnut pound cake with cabin
spiced icing
cow pee coffee and molasses a tribute to
famed american chef edna lewis
the woman who inspired tate and if you
notice that the plate itself
is very different from every other plate
i call these grandma plates because when
i was growing up
like myself and all my friends their
grandmas had the china cabinet
and there were a bunch of plates that
you don't touch unless it's a special
occasion
and so because she's my adopted culinary
grandma i wanted to put it on a very
beautiful plate for her
finally antebellum hudu with ingredients
he read about in a book about healing in
slave communities
sorghum peach jam black walnuts bone
marrow and chickweed
with burnt whiskey which came from a
woman named elsie
and a helping hand from his wife sybil
when you read records of things that
happened
especially during slavery like the
person who was enslaved is not named
especially not a black woman
so for this book to actually have her
name was very important to me
um my wife wrote a children's book
called elsie and so
that reading immediately connected me to
her and so the cup that this burnt
whiskey is in that's a burnt whiskey
tonic for health
is formed and shaped by sybil's hand so
that when the guest is dining
that's this yep yeah you're holding her
hand that's great
she's delivering new health that's great
ted has also created a small book of
remembrances
drawings and writings unlike any menu
we've ever seen
i get the sense that sometimes you have
a tough time getting out of your own
head
yeah yeah that's true and
the poetry helps with that yeah for sure
um it's definitely an outlet i've always
written in creating this concept
uh the poetry became really important
because i knew that if i started plating
dishes like
the black lung dish and said that it was
it represented black culture people
would like well it's a salad like how
does that represent black culture yeah
um and so the poetry emerged as a way
for me to get ahead of having to have a
conversation and justify what i'm doing
20 years from now where do you want to
be what do you want to be doing
uh teaching children how to live
and that means teaching them not just to
cook it means everything
anything anything and you know it's not
just me there's a
nigerian proverb that goes one tree does
not make a forest
right i am not i am not the sole person
or the knower of anything
really all i know is that i have the
capacity
to offer the gift that i've been given
to other people
he put so much thought into everything
he does
his one day dream is to open a community
center and cafe
and meat market and restaurants in west
philadelphia called honeysuckle
provisions
the honeysuckle pop-up was what he did
before that's the long-term
vision when he's done with this but i
have for you guys one of the
one of the best things something that's
become a hit there at stone barns right
now which is this parker house roll
right with the sweet potato stuffed
inside
it is so good they delivered them for us
just um last night we heated them up for
everybody
so anyway they're incredible so how do
you eat and then we'll take a bite
yeah no i was just thinking that after
that meal it didn't look like it was
rather
filling this might fill me up but got
the ice cream we got the kool-aid
we got the beef tartare we've got food
in your mouth